now jack carr is author of the
terminalist now a hit show on amazon
prime he's also a former navy seal
veteran who served in afghanistan jack
it's so good to see you thank you so
much for joining us
i know you have some thoughts and
feelings especially as we look at what
happened one year ago
i do and as does every person who went
over there and put their life on the
line and some who returned home facing
the uh
the physical and the emotional trauma of
their experience over there but we
learned early on in special operations
in particular to not rush to your death
and that means to take a breath look
around make a good
thoughtful call for those on your left
and right that's what you owe them
that's what you're their families that's
what you owe the mission and instead
what happened at a strategic level as we
got down to these final days in
afghanistan is we rushed to our death
and that's why so many americans who
never had any touch point with the
military whatsoever could apply a bit of
common sense to what they were seeing on
television and start asking questions
why did we give up bagram why did we put
our service members at a tactically
disadvantageous position at the kabul
airport which resulted unfortunately in
those deaths at abbey gate
and to say nothing of those who are
still dealing with those uh the the
physical wounds of that day and the
emotional wounds of that day we rushed
to our death at the end it was
unnecessary we had 20 years to learn
lessons and we neglected to do that we
didn't even go back to the soviet
experience in afghanistan we didn't go
back to the british experience we didn't
even have to go back to genghis khan or
alexander the great we had our own 20
years of experience in afghanistan and
we neglected to apply those lessons to
our withdrawal and it really is
unforgivable as is uh the the
accountability we have seen over that 20
years zero accountability from our
senior leaders
and that continues to this day they have
all failed upward
yeah jack i know you've spoken and
written a lot about this and about how
especially in recent history and you're
a student of history and a prolific
reader and author how uh general
officers are no longer held accountable
as you say they're promoted upward uh
what do you say to the families who are
looking for that accountability as we
wrap up here
well that's what we owe not just those
families but future generations as well
if we fail to take these lessons and
apply those lessons going forward as
wisdom uh then those deaths have been in
vain uh so we that's what we really owe
them is to apply those lessons going
forward as wisdom but we can look back
we can look back to what was our country
like before 1947 and after 1947. we
stopped holding our senior military
leaders accountable for whatever reason
after world war ii george marshall did
it before world war ii all through world
war ii put those generals and admirals
all those names that we know today as
those who led us to victory we all know
those names after world war ii we
stopped firing those admirals and those
generals who didn't measure up for
whatever reason and that continues today
and that's going to have to change if we
want the populists the citizens to trust
in our military leadership
and and the results speak for themselves
jack thank you for your service your
leadership and your voice i appreciate
it thanks for joining us
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight